The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today I want to walk
through that case in quotes.
It's more of a teaching
note than a case,
but there are some questions
to talk about and let
me pose one that probably
occurred to some of you
as you began reading the
course-- reading that case.
Why are we talking about EPA at
the front of a case on energy?
Sam?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
But especially it
can depends a lot
on where your energy comes from.
Like, [INAUDIBLE]
talked about how
the coal causes like a
lot of more [INAUDIBLE]
than [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So on
the one hand energy,
Energy is the source of
the kind of pollution
EPA was created to deal
with, and on the other hand--
STUDENT: Also the different
regulations impact [INAUDIBLE]
deductions [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So a lot
of energy policy
is made in under the umbrella
of environmental policy.
Plus or minus coal is not
going to be about coal,
but it's going to be about--
or not going to be about energy.
It's going to be
about the environment.
Let me call your attention.
This was an optional reading
but the National Academy
of Sciences unpriced
consequences paper is probably
the best recent summary
of this literature,
and it talks about putting
climate to one side.
We'll come back to that.
It credits coal-fired power
plants in 2005 with $62 billion
worth of damages--
externalities,
unpriced consequences
with a huge range per
kilowatt hour in the damages
caused by individual plants.
Natural gas fired power
plants, much less in aggregate
and, in fact, much less, except
for a few cases, per plant.
Transportation, both light
duty, cars and light trucks,
and heavy duty, heavy
trucks and equipment,
add up to about $56 billion.
Not that far off--
not that far off
coal-fired power plants.
The other interesting thing--
and we'll come back to this
later later today--
there's a little-- there's a
parenthetical assessment where
they say-- where they
look at alternative forms
of transportation alternative
power trains for cars,
and they conclude that electric
vehicles are much worse--
not much worse--
worse environmentally
than diesel, which, in turn, is
worse than gasoline or ethanol.
And the reason is, of
course, electric vehicles
across the country
are half coal-powered,
because that's where the
electricity comes from.
And this, sort of, gets
lost in the discussion.
But there are these numbers.
Where do they come from?
Where do you think they
come from? $62 billion
is not peeling paint.
$62 billion is mostly valuing
premature mortality, i.e.
people die.
There's a little bit
of health effects.
People get bronchitis.
But mostly, those numbers
are from people dying.
How would you do that?
Does it make sense to
compute numbers like that?
Does is it makes sense
to use numbers like that?
How would you use
numbers like that?
Do you believe
People say $62 billion
worth of damages.
Putting a price on human
life, putting a price on risk,
what do you think?
You read that,
what's your reaction?
How about a reaction?
Max, you've got a reaction?
STUDENT: Probably the cost of
medical expenses associated.
PROFESSOR: That be
one way to do it,
but that's not usually
how they do it.
See one of the--
if you do that, you can
come to the conclusion
that cigarette
smoking is terrific,
because people die at a
younger age if they smoke,
and therefore they don't have
the long care costs of people
in their 80s or
90s, because they
don't get to their 80s or 90s.
So you can measure costs of
sickness sometimes that way
but not death, not death.
Anybody else?
Julian?
STUDENT: What would be their
contribution to the GDP
and their economic
contribution is [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: That's
one way to do it.
Do you like that?
You could do it that way.
STUDENT: I would try and take
all their economic impact,
including the health costs,
their [INAUDIBLE] of tax base,
but how much they cost in taxes.
PROFESSOR: So basically
retired people--
and this is beginning to
beginning to bother me--
retired people should have
a negative value, right?
Because they're drawing
down social security.
They're drawing down Medicare.
They're not working.
Just gone.
So that method has been used.
It does have that
consequence I just described.
But for working age people--
and sometimes that's
done in court cases.
So someone is killed by
negligence and you sue.
And what do you get?
Well, one way that
sometimes calculated
is, well, how much money would--
the wife sues.
The husband was killed at work.
The wife gets the husband's
expected lifetime earnings.
That isn't what they do
here because a lot of this
is mortality of
older people, and you
don't want to come up
with a negative number.
The way they do it--
because it's a little
bit of a little bit
of a puzzle-- the way they
do it is they look at,
at least recently, you look at
weight premiums for risky jobs.
So you say, how
much more does it
take to persuade somebody to
be a welder underwater, which
is a bit hazardous than
they'd be a welder on land.
And a number of
calculations like that.
Because you're not actually
valuing a death when you do
these studies.
You're valuing an
increase in risk.
So you increase
the risk of death.
And you say, all right,
well, in the marketplace,
what are people willing--
what does it
require, what do you
have to pay people to get them
to assume an increased risk
of death in certain settings?
And then you play with that for
a while, make some assumptions,
roll it around, and say the
value of a premature death
$6 million, which is a
round number that's used.
And then you say, OK.
We look at how many
people we expect
will die early because
of small particulates
from coal-fired power plants.
And we value that at
$6 million apiece.
So you're not valuing a death
so much as you're valuing
an increased risk of death.
So that's how you do it.
Should you use numbers like
that to make decisions?
There were some readings
on whether cost benefit
analysis is ethical.
And some of it comes to that.
STUDENT: The person [INAUDIBLE]
not really [INAUDIBLE]..
I wouldn't place to much
attention on the very specific,
value, per se.
Maybe it would be--
for me, at least--
it would be like relatively-- so
the same basic assumptions made
for any different source,
maybe coal or natural gas.
Maybe we see these
values relative.
So it's much higher for coal
than for natural gas, just
given the case between the two.
But I wouldn't do a whole
analysis saying, OK, $6 million
here and $6 million there.
They could get cancer,
to OK, I mean--
PROFESSOR: But you
got to know something
about not just
relative, but absolute,
to know whether it matters.
If I told you the damages were
$5 from coal-fired power plants
and $0.35 from gas-fired, that
wouldn't affect any decisions.
If I told you it was $500
billion versus $200 million,
that would drive a decision.
So I take your point,
but sometimes you've
got to have a sense
of the absolute,
not just the relative.
STUDENT: May I ask--
PROFESSOR: Of course.
STUDENT: --is there any
sense at least of error,
or a band number of these--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
I mean, all this stuff
is subject to error.
Take coal fired-power plants.
Take a particular plant.
First thing you're doing
is you're estimating where
the stuff from that plant goes.
OK, so that's a transport
model of one kind or another,
which is averaging over a
bunch of weather conditions.
And then you're using--
and there's error there, because
you can't measure that well--
and then you're using a
dose response curve based
on a number of different
kinds of studies
to say, if this
area gets this kind
of particulate concentration
over this period of time-- oh,
by the way, how much time do
people spend outside breathing
it versus inside?
Et cetera, et cetera.
Then we would expect this
increase in the risk of death
for people in this age bracket.
Sure, there are error bars.
You don't see them, but there
are pretty good size error
bars.
In fact, critics say they're
very wide error bars.
And similarly, the
human life, even
the people who do
this stuff, you're
comparing a risk voluntarily
assumed with a risk imposed.
How many of you
ride motorcycles?
How many of you ridden
on a motorcycle?
This is a risky activity.
This increased your probability
of death significantly.
You didn't think about it.
If I told you,
however, we were going
to pump poisonous gas into your
room that had the same effect,
you'd go crazy.
People distinguish between
risks they choose to assume
and risks that are imposed.
And I don't know
how to value that.
So you had a comment?
Yeah.
STUDENT: I think this is
useful for bringing attention
to an issue, rather than
the decision-making.
Because when you
come to policymakers,
they want a number that they
can associate with the issue.
PROFESSOR: Actually,
policymakers
tend to hate this
stuff because there
is this value in
human life aspect.
STUDENT: But when you go
through all the different steps.
You go through all the
inputs, all the assumptions.
They don't want to
go through all that.
They want to compare numbers.
PROFESSOR: Well,
we'll see in a second.
Distinguish different
kinds of policymakers.
But people who are
looking for votes
do not like to say a human
life is worth $6 million
or say anything that
sounds like a human life is
worth $6 million,
because it's priceless.
Saying it's priceless
doesn't get you
a decision unless you can make
some other assumptions, which
they did.
STUDENT: Well, when
they use that number,
they don't publicize the
fact that it is [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: I mean, every
presidential administration
since, depending on how you
think about it, Carter--
but certainly since Reagan--
Republicans and Democrats have
done this kind of analysis
quietly.
OK, anything else?
Yes.
STUDENT: I had a quick question
about the electric vehicle
statistic.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: Is that based on
electric vehicles that are only
run of coal-fired plants?
Or is that--
PROFESSOR: Assume the average
generation mix, I think.
You can go back and check.
But I think that's
what it said--
that assuming the average
mix, which gets you
about half coal ballpark.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Just to confirm,
they did not price carbon--
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Not in those, they didn't.
There's a discussion--
again, you can look at it--
of relative carbon
emissions, right?
And coal gives you about
twice per kilowatt hour
what gas gives you in
terms of carbon emissions.
And they talk a little
bit about transportation.
Now, I guess we won't.
I was going to say we will come
to some discussion of pricing
carbon.
The Obama administration
has an official value
for carbon emissions that it
uses for internal decisions.
It sounds like a
reasonable number,
but it rests on weak
foundations because--
we'll talk about
this, but trying
to understand the magnitude of
climate damages in a century
and discounting it back
is a difficult exercise.
OK.
Let me move along.
I want to talk about this
property rights analysis
because I think it's
useful to think about.
There are those people who
actually said that where
you really don't need this kind
of government interference.
You could just assign property
rights to either, say,
clean air or clean
water, or property
rights to dump pollution and
let the market sort it out.
This is the so-called
Coase theorem.
And the example that's given in
the Viscusi et cetera reading
is this one.
You have a mill.
You have a river.
And you have a town.
The mill dumps pollution
into the river.
The town takes water
out of the river.
There's $500 worth of damage.
OK, so drinking
the polluted water
or using it to wash
clothes or whatever
causes $500 worth of damages.
The mill could clean
it up for $100.
The town could treat
the water for $300.
The argument goes, there
is no problem here.
We just need to assign
property rights.
Suppose you say that the town
is entitled to clean water.
The town is entitled
to clean water.
The town takes legal
action against the mill.
The mill spends
$100 and cleans up.
Simple.
Suppose the mill is
entitled to pollute.
Give them the property right.
Then what happens?
The town could
clean up for $300.
But what would most likely
happen is they go to the mill
and say, look, we'll pay
you something over $100
to clean up.
Something between $100-300.
You're going to pay
them more than $300
because you could
do it yourself.
They're not going to
take less than $100.
So there's some bargaining room.
You're going to get rid
of the damages either way
because it's cheaper to get
rid of them than to bear them.
And either way, what happens
is the mill cleans up.
In one case, the mill pays.
In the other case,
the town pays.
But in both cases,
the mill cleans up,
the pollution goes away,
and all you had to do
is assign property rights.
So first of all, are there
questions about that?
Does that make
that little example
makes sense in its own terms?
Yeah?
STUDENT: What does
the mill need-
like, the mill is
polluting, then
they're sort of claiming
those rights anyway, right?
So then--
PROFESSOR: Well, we have that
happen at the outset, and then
we and then we establish
property rights.
Then we establish
So this is the status quo
before we put the law in effect,
and what the law says is instead
of yelling at each other,
one of you has the
right to enforce action
against the other in court.
So either the town can
force the mill to clean up
or the mill can do
whatever it wants
unless it's bribed or paid.
So we start out with a situation
in which there are no property
rights.
The mill is polluting,
the town is complaining.
We assign property
rights, the problem
gets solved, is the argument.
Either way, we assign them.
STUDENT: Are property rights
necessary for the town
to clean up the water?
Because [INAUDIBLE] river
and they want water.
PROFESSOR: Well, if the town--
I mean, you could imagine
what property rights determine
here is who pays, basically.
Because if the-- which thing
is, if you don't have property
rights, the town's going to
go up here and try to bargain.
Because you're
saying, implicitly,
unless you do something,
the mill just pollutes.
Well, that's equivalent to
saying the mill has the right
to pollute.
If the mill has the
right to pollute,
then the town is going to
have to pay them not to.
If the town has the
right to clean water,
then the mill is either going
to have to clean up or pay
the town to clean up.
It's cheaper for the mill.
The mill cleans up.
So if you say the mill
is just going to pollute,
not if the town can stop it.
Not if the town can stop it.
That comes to the next
question, is why won't it work?
One way one reason it might
not work in a real life case
is the town doesn't
happen to have chemists
and doesn't realize
that the water is dirty.
So you might want to say,
gee, a role of government
is to do some science
here, at least,
and figure out what's going on
to do the studies of damages.
And I want to make
sure everybody's
got the example before
we go to run down
this list a little bit.
But are you on the example?
Or are you on why
it might not work?
STUDENT: I'm on the
example I was wondering,
how do you decide who
gets the property right?
PROFESSOR: Coase's point
is it doesn't matter.
I mean, it matters from the
point of view of fairness,
maybe.
You might say it's fair
to have the polluter pay.
But Coase's point of view is
you clean it up either way.
His example was,
in fact, a train.
And this was a
coal-fired steam engine
running by a farmer's field.
Sparks come out of
the smokestacks.
Sparks start fires.
The farmer can put out
the fires or the railroad
can clean up the smokestack.
Whoever has the
property rights are
going to get the lower-cost
alternative done.
STUDENT: One thing
with that scenario
or with the mill scenario,
even if the mill had property
rights, then wouldn't
the town want
to bribe them either
way, whether or not
they have the property rights?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Well, if the town
has property rights,
it doesn't have to bribe.
It can compel.
It'll bribe if it
has no alternative.
That is to say, if the mill
has the right to pollute,
then it'll have to bribe.
If the town has the
right, it can sue.
It can compel.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Also assuming
the cost of damages
is greater than the--
the $500 is greater than the
$300, which may be true--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it could--
if I make this 50,
then nobody cleans up.
That's $50 worth of damages,
then the mill has the right.
The town isn't going
to spend $100 or more
to save itself $50
worth of damages.
And if the town has
the right, well, that's
actually an
interesting question.
If the town has the right to
clean water, in that case,
would it compel the
mill to clean up?
I think you get the bargain
going the other way.
You get the bargain going.
You've got the right
to clean water.
The mill pays them $60
to accept the damages.
The mill covers the
cost of the damages
because the efficient
thing, in this case,
is not to clean up,
assuming this is
a number that makes some sense.
OK.
Anything else on this?
OK, why do we need EPA?
Why don't we just do this?
One answer is, gee, there's
an information problem
in a lot of these areas.
So maybe a role of government
is to do the science,
tell people about it,
make sure the town knows,
make sure the mill knows.
Maybe even work on
clean-up technologies.
All perfectly sensible things.
And then assign
property rights, right?
Yeah?
STUDENT: It's really
complicated, say,
if you had five miles
ahead of the town
and they're all
polluting, and then you
have the case
where one mill says
it pollutes less so it
should have to clean up less.
And then it's just a huge
argument over monetary value.
PROFESSOR: And let's
suppose we have six towns.
OK, so you can have--
so let me just
write a little bit.
The first thing we talked about
that made the cameras move.
The first thing we talked
about was information.
And the second point here
is number of players.
There's just a whole lot that
comes under that heading.
If you think about applying
it to air pollution,
so there's a coal-fired power
plant in Salem, Massachusetts.
The coal-fired power plant in
Salem, Massachusetts is dirty.
Everybody in Salem
and around Salem
gets affected, to some extent.
How does this work?
I give every person
property rights?
And how do 20,000, 30,000
people act collectively?
Sue in court.
So when you have more than
these simple examples,
it gets to be hard.
And the other one,
just to fill it out,
is just transaction costs.
In a world in which everybody
is suing everybody else one way
or another and bargaining
over cleanup costs,
that's a world in which a lot
of money is spent doing that.
So the usual argument
here is, well, this
is a lovely exercise.
And it does make a
good point, I think.
But frankly, when you
go to the real world,
you need a different mechanism
to deal with externalities.
So that's an argument for
involving the government.
It's not necessarily an
argument for involving
the federal government.
Before 1970, most states
had environmental agencies.
Why do we need a federal agency?
This is a cue for
all the Republicans.
Go ahead.
STUDENT: The president decides
that it's OK to pollute a lot.
That could be in the atmosphere
and affect the states
that border.
PROFESSOR: So pollution
across state lines.
Absolutely.
Anything else cross state lines?
David?
STUDENT: I was just going to say
it crosses national lines, too.
PROFESSOR: We'll see-- when we
talk about acid rain-- we'll
see that that pollution
crossing the Canadian border
turned out to have an
important implication.
It does cross national lines,
but since we don't have a world
government, having a
world pollution agency
is not an option, although there
are international agreements.
The Montreal
Protocol that phased
out ozone-depleting chemicals
was an example of exactly that.
People got together to
solve a global problem.
Climate change is harder.
Brendan?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Electricity
crosses state lines,
so what you're
saying is you could
generate in some
place that's dirty
and sell to someplace
that's clean
and disadvantage the entities
in the collinear state.
Anything else?
Ryan?
STUDENT: Well, there's
not only air pollution.
There's also river pollution,
including the Mississippi
River.
But also, if you--
I don't know if it's the case--
but if you mine in one state and
it gets dirty from the mining,
and you sell it to
a different state,
there's like some sort
of transaction there.
PROFESSOR: And there's
a transaction there?
Anything else you
might worry about--
if you're a clean state
that you might worry about?
Yeah, Max.
STUDENT: I mean, it's
the economic thing.
So if one state decides that
they're going to deregulate
and allow pollution to go
[INAUDIBLE] tax reductions
in states that are cleaning
the economically poor
because corporations--
PROFESSOR: The that
everybody has is jobs--
is that you'll
basically be Mississippi
decides that it
really needs jobs.
It's a low-income,
low-wage state.
So apart from being
tough on labor unions,
it's also going to be
real easy on pollution.
And everybody in
Mississippi says,
well, I don't like
to breathe that air,
but I'd like to have a job.
You have a race to the
bottom, so to speak.
And pollution, it's a worry.
Whether it happens
or doesn't happen,
it's a worry that you really
needed some national standards
or some national something.
But let me pause
and I'm just going
to pose a question that we
we'll come back to later
in the course, which is
how come it happened?
For all the years, people
worry about dirty air
and dirty water.
This isn't a new concern.
There's a very old act that
forbids discharge of anything
into the navigable waters
of the United States.
It's been ignored since it was
written in the 19th century,
but pollution wasn't
discovered in 1970.
A Republican president signed
the Clean Air Act amendments
and created EPA in 1970.
And there's a historical
answer to the events
that led up to it.
But I'd like you to think about
the fundamental question-- is
what turned the politics from
absolutely nothing going on
at the federal level to a new
agency with strong mandates.
Don't answer that question.
We're going to do it later.
You're going to say Earth Day.
And I'm going to
say that's right.
And then we're going to say,
where did Earth Day come from?
So we've got EPA.
But as the case says, I
mean, this comes down to,
do policymakers like numbers?
What the law said-- these
are the National Ambient Air
Quality Standards.
So one of EPA'S jobs
is to say, how clean
must the air be everywhere
in the United States?
And you could imagine doing
that in two different ways.
You could imagine doing those
kinds of damage numbers,
damages at different
levels of air quality,
and look at the costs of
obtaining different levels
of air quality.
Do the maximize
benefits minus cost.
What the law told
EPA to do, however,
was to protect human health with
an adequate margin of safety.
Why do you think they did that
as opposed to good old cost
benefit analysis, which every
economist would tell them
they should have done?
And that law has been
in effect since 1970
with every economist saying
that doesn't make any sense.
Take a guess.
Somebody who hasn't spoken yet.
Rachel, what do you think?
STUDENT: Politics.
PROFESSOR: Politics.
But what kind of politics?
STUDENT: In the sense
that the president is
creating this agency that
could be in charge of this.
It might be related to
the cost benefit analysis.
PROFESSOR: But he has
to do an analysis.
He has to protect human
health with an adequate margin
of safety.
And that analysis
will be challenged.
It'll be challenged by industry.
It'll be challenged by
the environmentalists.
So you don't just
make up the numbers.
You have to show that you're
protecting human health
and you have to put in an
adequate margin of safety.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] the EPA--
I forget the exact number.
It's like one in every
10,000 different risk factors
depending on what it is.
But that sounds like, oh, only
one out of every 100,000 people
is going to get cancer, versus
we're saying you getting cancer
is worth X amount of costs.
PROFESSOR: I think
it's the optics.
I think that's right.
This assumes that there is some
level below which you're safe
and above which you're not safe.
And if we just get
away get a little bit
below that low level,
we're all safe.
The evidence, as far as I
know, on all these pollutants
is it smooth.
There is no threshold.
The law presumes the threshold
because that's easier
to talk about.
And then, internally,
you can say, well,
we'll use a one in a million
or one in 10 million,
or something like that.
And then you can say we're
protecting human health.
You don't have to stand up
and say, valuing a human life
at $6 million, dot, dot, dot.
It is the optics.
And I think everybody
who's thought about this
understands that-- that this
is an illogical criteria.
It means as you get better and
better at measuring things,
you have to set tighter and
tighter standards because you
detect human health effects at
lower and lower concentrations,
which is not
necessarily a bad thing,
but it's kind of inevitable
and kind of artificial.
Why not just use a price?
So why not, instead
of setting standards--
this is an example from the
graph from the reading--
suppose that-- and it deals
with a very simple case.
Suppose that here
is the marginal cost
of producing gasoline, let us
say, and there's the demand.
So this would be the
equilibrium with no regulation.
And Viscusi says,
well, suppose we
know the damages per
gallon of gasoline produced
is given by the distance
between these two curves.
So we tax the
production of gasoline.
Again, a simple model.
We suppose that's the problem.
We put a tax equal
to this amount here,
then the equilibrium
is at the point where
production cost plus the
marginal value of damages
equals the market price.
You don't want to produce
less because the total cost
production plus damages
is less than the amount
the market's willing to pay.
You don't want to produce
more because the total cost
on the margin, the total
cost for additional units,
exceeds what the
market's willing to pay.
So you impose the marginal
cost of damages as a price.
Everything is swell.
Economists are happy.
And you used the price system.
Why might you not
want to do that?
Well, maybe you do.
Why would that be hard?
Let me just start there.
Part of the reason you
don't do it is the optics.
Again, you'd rather say we're
protecting human health than
we're imposing a marginal tax
of $0.60 a gallon to reflect
environmental the value
of human life lost.
That's not a great headline.
But suppose you could
find a way to disguise it.
Suppose you just do it.
This is the charge.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Well, if you're
going to tax, say,
coal, more than you would tax
oil for having high damages,
there's also reasons to
tax oil more than coal
because oil's imported
and coal is domestic.
So how do you--
PROFESSOR: We'll do
all the arithmetic.
We'll figure out
the marginal value
of reduced energy security.
We'll figure out the marginal
value of CO2 emissions.
And we'll figure out
the marginal value
of-- marginal cost, rather--
of a little bitty particulates
that get in your
lung and kill you.
And we'll just add them up.
STUDENT: And then
you're really getting
into the optics of
showing how much you're
valuing a human life in
comparison to things like--
PROFESSOR: Even if
you could-- well,
I mean, economists
all love this.
You do have the optics problem.
The other problem you
got to is that's hard.
That's hard, right?
Because you saw that range of
damages for coal-fired power
plants because that
reflects where they are.
So you'd want to
do this calculation
at least for every
coal-fired power plant.
Every gas-fired power plant,
and oh, by the way, every car.
Because the damages depend on
where you drive and how far
you drive.
So you'd want to have
taxes for everything.
Now, as an economist, that's
little short of paradise.
But as a practical matter,
that's really hard.
That's really hard.
So what you get instead--
there are prices, occasionally--
we'll talk about some systems
that are price-driven--
where it's easier.
Suppose you're
worried about climate.
Well, to a first approximation,
carbon dioxide goes in the air.
Carbon dioxide mixes globally.
You don't care
where it comes from.
You could have a single
price for carbon dioxide.
Mercury from coal-fired
power plants, the damages
depend on where the plant is.
So if you're going
to do prices, you're
going to have to do
different prices.
That's hard.
Sometimes it's not
quite right that it
doesn't matter where it comes
from but it's close enough.
David?
STUDENT: It's only really hard
if you want to do it right.
So what the EPA
does now where you
said they said some standard
of like, how much pollution you
can put out, but they just kind
of hit the limit arbitrarily.
PROFESSOR: And then--
well, they do two things.
They do two things that
the case talks about.
They do other things, as well.
But the two things the
case talks about is they
set air quality standards.
And they say everywhere
in the country
the air has to meet
these certain standards.
Well, you could say,
gee, it makes sense
to let the air be
dirty in Los Angeles
because it's really hard
to clean it in Los Angeles.
You can argue about
whether that makes sense.
But they don't do that.
The other thing they do
is they set standards
and they let the states
figure out how to do that.
Look, Ohio's got to be clean.
Illinois has got to be clean.
Figure out what to do.
If you can find a
way to minimize cost,
even if you want to
price stuff to do it.
You, the states, figure
out how to do it.
We'll check your plan to
see if it's going to work,
but you give us a plan.
That's not terrible.
Not great, but
it's not terrible.
Then the other thing they do--
that the case
mentions-- is they set
standards for new power plants.
And those are the
same everywhere.
And you can argue, yes, no,
is that the right thing to do?
But it's better than
you tell me where
you're going to put the
plant, I'll calculate the tax.
Because that's hard.
A lot of what goes
on here is you
have two imperfect approaches.
And I'm just saying that
while this is really
a textbook ideal, it's hard.
And while what EPA
actually does isn't
very good from a textbook point
of view, it sort of works--
particularly, the air standards.
A lot of us would
say, look, Los Angeles
is really hard to clean up.
Let them be dirty.
And of course,
that's practically
what happens because it's
been impossible to clean
LA to meet national standards.
But at least the principle
is if you move to LA,
you're entitled to clean air.
So nobody's doing it perfectly.
The question is, which
of the imperfect methods
is A, workable
and B, reasonable?
And all I'm saying
is that you don't
want to get caught up
in the beauty of this
without thinking about the
complexity of doing it.
Really, you could
say, all right.
If I'm concerned about
acid rain in the east,
then I will make I
will act as if it
doesn't matter where sulfur
dioxide goes up into the air.
Does it matter?
Yes, it matters.
Does it matter a lot?
Well, not so much
within certain bounds.
So yeah, It's not quite right.
But I'll use that assumption.
It'll let me do something
I couldn't do otherwise.
STUDENT: Does it matter
who the rain is falling on?
PROFESSOR: Well, it does matter
who the rain is falling on.
Let's hold this for
about four weeks.
And then I want to go
into that in detail.
Yeah, in the back.
STUDENT: I had a question.
How do you handle
[INAUDIBLE] factors?
Something that jumps
to my mind is farming.
You use pesticides,
or ammonia fertilizers
that get into the water.
And not using those
reduces food production.
What do if you have increased
environmental risk of dying?
On the other side, you
also have increased
risk of more expensive food,
or not enough food, or things
like that.
PROFESSOR: Well, actually,
that's a little off track.
That turns out to be hard.
We control-- this is not, of
course, about water pollution.
And I don't want to
spend much time on it.
But we control point sources.
So if you have that mill
over there, EPA will limit,
or the state will limit--
I'm not sure how that works--
what you can put in the water.
If you have a form that's
called nonpoint source.
You get runoff.
You could imagine, in theory,
doing cost benefit calculations
about comparing increases
in food production costs
with ecosystem damage--
which is largely
what you're getting,
you're getting phosphates and
other nutrients in the water
that damage
ecosystems and such--
as well as increased
cleanup costs downstream.
And that might tell you
what level of fertilizer use
is optimal or with certain
products should and shouldn't
be used.
Enforcement is a little tough.
So we really don't control
nonpoint source water pollution
very well in this country.
And I was involved in
discussions in Washington 20
years ago now about, can we
think about how to do this?
And it's just a head-scratcher.
Because you really don't
want the black helicopters
over every farm, but you
know what's the alternative?
So let me move along here.
So we've talked about a
number of these things.
Oh, one of the other things--
let me just go to the next.
So this is EPA.
It's November 1974.
What just happened?
Why do we all of a
sudden care about energy?
Scott?
You are Scott.
You're not Scott.
You don't have a name card.
He's Scott.
Who are you pretending
to be today?
STUDENT: Sean.
PROFESSOR: Sean, OK.
STUDENT: Oil prices?
PROFESSOR: Oil prices.
What did they do?
STUDENT: Embargo.
OPEC.
PROFESSOR: OPEC
imposed an embargo.
It didn't keep oil
from getting to us,
but the prices went way up.
So Nixon, all of a
sudden we talk about,
we're very threatened.
The Arab countries
wouldn't ship to us.
We got oil.
It doesn't matter oil.
Tankers go to sea.
The tankers go where
the tankers go.
People buy them at
sea and redirect them.
So we got oil.
But Nixon says we need to
be independent by 1980.
So first question is, what does
energy independence do for you?
And is energy independence the
same thing as energy security?
And how is this how important
is it, if it's important?
Reactions?
Was that the right goal?
Was that a right goal?
Forget the fact that
we failed miserably.
Was that worth
spending money on?
A lot of money?
And if so, why?
And if not, why not?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] any energy
sources from other countries,
but at the same
time, a global energy
crisis happened in the
world, you would still
be affected because
you're only independent,
but other products that you are
importing from other countries
still depends on
the energy crisis.
PROFESSOR: Well, did
everybody get that?
The argument is that if there
is a major energy crisis,
even if we're not importing
any oil, which is what matters,
will be affected.
You're saying will be affected
because we will import things
from countries
that are affected.
Import other things.
We'll also export to countries
that may have trouble buying.
But also I mean, you saw the
diagrams for Western Europe.
These are long-term allies.
Our policy will be
affected if suddenly--
suppose Russia turns
off the gas pipeline.
Do we just say to our
European friends and allies,
buy some wool socks.
It's going to get cold.
No.
Our policy is affected.
So one argument is even if
you're energy independent,
you don't live behind a wall.
Any other thoughts?
Just agree, disagree.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] is in
coal, so we don't necessarily
want to be running
independently on coal
because it pollutes more.
PROFESSOR: OK, so it matters
how you become independent.
OK.
Good point.
There's a trade off.
There may be a trade off.
If you have nice, cheap
natural gas, maybe not so much.
But, yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
consideration
for energy security.
We decide to become energy
independent by relying
on nuclear, and that makes
us vulnerable to an attack
on a nuclear plant, for example.
PROFESSOR: Security has
multiple dimensions.
So you might be vulnerable
to terrorist attacks
on nuclear plants the way
you wouldn't necessarily
be vulnerable if say
you're getting oil
from Canada by pipeline.
Also may depend who you're
getting your energy from.
Yeah?
Max?
I'll go back.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
security, looking at that,
I've always though
energy independence
doesn't necessarily imply
security implications
as a matter of
national interest.
We're the largest importer
of oil in the world.
We stop importing oil from
countries like Saudi Arabia
and other countries
in the Middle East
and they might not be
so happy to help Assad
if Israel goes south.
PROFESSOR: That's an
interesting hypothetical.
Yeah?
Good point, though.
Good point.
There's a lot of
other connections.
I can't read it.
Could be James.
OK.
STUDENT: If it costs too much
to be energy independent,
it probably will
hurt the economy.
PROFESSOR: Could be
too expensive to do.
OK, actually, let me give you
let me give you two scenarios.
One, all of our oil is--
we have the same total
energy use that we have now.
All of our oil is imported.
We import five barrels a day.
The other case is we're
energy independent.
We use twice as much
oil as we do today.
So one case, we have no imports.
The other case, we
have all imports.
In which case are
we more secure?
Which case are we
less vulnerable?
Let me put it that way.
Lots of oil, all domestic,
versus a little bit of oil,
all imported.
What are the risks?
What are the risks
you worry about?
Yeah?
STUDENT: If you import, I
guess there's multiple sources
and more negotiation.
Whereas if you're all
self-sufficient, in a sense,
if something were
to go wrong, you'd
have nowhere to go with it.
PROFESSOR: Well,
I didn't say there
was nobody else in the world.
I just said all of
our oil is domestic.
There are still tankers.
There are still ports.
There's still the world market.
Manuel?
STUDENT: If all the
oil is domestic,
we might run out in
the next few years.
PROFESSOR: Right let's
assume we got lucky.
We got so we got lucky.
We have a lot of it.
Jake?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
much more expensive.
It's kind of like the same
as you have in sugar--
PROFESSOR: All right, let
me make a nice hypothetical.
Same cost.
We're producing world prices.
Let me lead you in the
direction I want to go.
Suppose the world price doubles.
In which scenario do
we get hurt worse?
A little bit of oil all
imported, a lot of oil
all domestic?
STUDENT: I guess if world
prices were doubled,
we'd be hurt less
if all our oil--
PROFESSOR: Oh, so you
would separate our prices
from the world price?
Oh, I didn't say
it was separate.
I just said we produced it all.
Britain was self-sufficient
in oil for a long time.
STUDENT: We would export it.
So I guess we might--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: What would happen--
STUDENT: We would export oil
because we'd make more money.
PROFESSOR: Straight.
So wouldn't you expect
the domestic price
to equal the world
price in both cases?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we use a lot of oil.
The price doubles.
Versus a little bit of
oil and the price doubles.
STUDENT: Using less oil.
PROFESSOR: Using less
oil would make us
less vulnerable to that shock.
So the amount of oil matters
as much as where it comes from.
The difference is, do the
checks go to Saudi Arabia
or do they go to Texas?
Or now North Dakota.
But if you drive a car it
doesn't much matter to you.
It's still a doubling
of your cost.
Yeah?
STUDENT: During the crisis,
I think it became important
not only for strategic,
political reasons,
but also because the public
perception changed completely
because Americans never really
had faced an overall energy
crisis.
It's not just about price.
People would go to
the gas stations
and they couldn't get gas.
So there was actually a supply--
PROFESSOR: Well,
that was in '79.
And that's actually-- because I
was actually taking a long road
trip during that.
And that was in fact, because
of government regulation.
We decided we'd hold
the domestic price down
and that made it
hard to get gas.
People panicked.
But let me hold off.
We'll come to later.
So I'm going to
answer this one just
in the interest of moving along.
Project Independence.
Independence is a nice-sounding
goal, but it's not necessarily,
if you think it through-- and
there's a nice recommended
piece on the list about this--
not necessarily the
most important goal.
You might want to use less
oil, period, since oil
is what oil is very volatile.
OK, it's '75.
I'll answer this, too,
because we're moving slowly.
Oil prices have
been pretty stable
since it's only been a year.
Here is the choice.
CAFE standards on cars
or a gasoline tax?
Which do you do?
You're on President Ford's
council of economic advisors.
In fact, one of my teachers
was on President Ford's council
of economic advisors.
Which do you think he
advised Ford to support?
Standards for motor vehicles
or taxes on gasoline?
And why?
Which would you
support, and why?
STUDENT: He probably supported
standards of regulation
because taxes are fairly
unpopular and I understand
it's--
PROFESSOR: So the
political argument
would be can't say tax or
somebody will shoot you.
Put that aside for
a moment and we'll
assume you could actually
say the word tax out loud.
There was a time when you
could in this country.
Yeah?
STUDENT: If you opposed
the tax, then everybody
has to pay equally and
there is no incentive
to buy [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, the
more expensive gasoline
is the more expensive a gas
guzzler is for you to own.
So you'd expect gasoline prices
to change vehicle purchases,
right?
So it doesn't remove
the incentive for me
to decide what to buy.
From General Motors'
point of view, sure.
If you buy a guzzler,
I'll make a guzzler.
The tax would work
through consumers.
Andreas?
STUDENT: I think it depends
on what your goal is.
[INAUDIBLE] but if your
goal is to reduce pollution,
for example, I would think they
would make more sense to tax
because I would say that, in
terms of making engines more
efficient, I think the
gas price itself would
lead to more for the country.
Because if gas prices
are very expensive,
you'd want to get cars that
are more efficient, like we
have with airplanes right
now and stuff like that.
You would have engines more
efficient so you can use less.
And I think it's fair for
an issue like pollution
where everybody can pay for
it as opposed to people who--
PROFESSOR: What are the
different-- good points.
What are the different
effects on the cost
of driving once you own a car?
STUDENT: I was going to say,
with you the CAFE standards,
if you have a more
efficient engine,
you might be also
encouraged to drive more.
PROFESSOR: Driving
is cheaper, yeah.
STUDENT: It's cheaper
as opposed to like
taking with bus or something.
PROFESSOR: I was going to
let Julian get the answer,
but you probably
have another point.
STUDENT: Well, I
was going to talk
about where the cost [INAUDIBLE]
tax or a CAFE program
to make work more [INAUDIBLE].
Because motor vehicles
are a relatively-- like,
in the last decade, you
still have to drive to work.
You still have to go
to school Et cetera.
Et cetera.
But if you have a
motor vehicle tax,
that would probably
pass onto something
like manufacturers
and they would--
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
Motor fuels tax will raise the
cost of gasoline at retail.
That's what it's supposed to do.
Yeah.
STUDENT: I mean, it
depends on [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: First approximation
is it's the consumer, right?
If it costs more to
make efficient cars,
the consumer will pay.
If gasoline prices rise,
So on that level,
it's probably a wash.
The question is the
impact on incentives.
Let me pose you one.
Suppose I have an
old gas guzzler.
I have an old car that
gets lousy mileage.
You do a gas tax or
you do a CAFE standard.
What are the impacts on
me, and what do I do?
STUDENT: Well with
the cafe standard,
your car might cost
more initially.
PROFESSOR: No, I own it.
It's an old car.
It's a 1966 Pontiac Bonneville.
It gets twp miles to the
gallon, but the sound is good.
OK?
You've imposed a CAFE
standard on 2011 model cars
or you've doubled the gas tax.
What do I do in those two cases?
Maybe I scrap the car, right?
Maybe I scrap the car
earlier because it's
more expensive to
run than a new car.
So I do want to cover
a little more ground.
Most economists would say you'd
want the gas tax because it
affects driving, it
affects all drivers,
and ultimately, you expect it
to affect motor vehicle design
because you've changed
buying incentives.
The counter is people react
slowly to price changes.
You might not get the
effect you want right away.
The politics are not
as good Yeah Scott?
STUDENT: Excuse me.
I think of the
modern day example
back in 2008 and 2009
when gas prices went up
to like $4 a gallon, then
people's buying preferences
did change.
A lot of people started
buying smaller cars.
More compact vehicles and SUVs
sales were really hit hard.
So I think that
kind of shows that--
PROFESSOR: There
are a lot of papers
on this they come
to the conclusion
that there certainly
is an effect, how
big the effective is, how
long lasting the effective is.
A lot of debate.
But certainly in 1980
when prices spiked,
there was a big shift
to economy cars.
What else might we
have done to use
less petroleum besides either
a gas tax or a CAFE standard?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Carpool program.
PROFESSOR: Carpool program.
Getting warm.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Improve
public transportation?
PROFESSOR: Subsidizing
public transportation
is sort of the European
answer to it, which
is, instead of getting
the cars more efficient,
get the people out of the cars.
And there was a little
bit of discussion of that,
but that's not terribly
popular, particularly
in spread-out Western cities.
If you compare Boston,
which is fairly dense,
with a Los Angeles, or a
Denver, or a Salt Lake City,
public transportation's
tough because the cities
were built for cars.
So it's a longstanding debate.
I'm going to move quickly.
President Carter's
packing his bags.
What's happened to oil prices?
It's late 1980.
Do you remember
the hostage rescue?
You don't remember
the hostage rescue.
The hostage
non-rescue in Tehran?
Oil prices spiked.
So now we come to coal
because the proposal is, look,
we know how to make
liquid fuels out of coal.
Germany did it in
the Second World War.
People have been experimenting
with it since the 20s.
This is not magic.
Processes can get better.
Catalysts can be improved.
But basically, we know how to
make liquid fuels out of coal.
We're sitting on a ton of coal.
Ton understates it.
We're sitting on lots of coal.
We are the Saudi Arabia of coal.
Why are we fooling around here?
Why don't we do a synthetic
fuels industry in this country
as they did in Germany, as
they did in Japan, as they
did and are still
doing in South Africa,
and make liquid fuels from
coal and use American coal?
So good idea.
And climate was not on
the table at this point.
So climate is not a
consideration for Carter.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] process
where I remember from Germany
doing it during World War II,
it was their last ditch effort
because they were
basically isolated
from the rest of the world.
PROFESSOR: When they got cut
off from the Iranian oil.
Right.
STUDENT: They had to fuel their
war machine by themselves.
So that was their only
option is to turn to--
I think they exhausted all
of those supplies, too.
PROFESSOR: Well
they made a dent.
They made a dent.
So one thing you
want to think about--
and we talked about this--
is gee, it might be expensive.
So one thing you
might want to know,
the answer to that
question is, well,
what's this stuff going
to cost per gallon?
Can you give me a number?
And if it's five times the
market price, maybe not.
And if it's 1 and
1/2 times the--
well, we're in 1980.
And in 1980, oil
prices have gone up
like that and all
the forecasts called
on them to continue to rise.
It's a great story of how
forecasts extrapolate.
Every published
forecast said that they
were going to continue to rise
in the event that collapsed.
But in any case, you
might want to know
how the cost would compare.
Anything else you might
want to think about?
Scott?
STUDENT: If the synthetic
fuels industry starts off well
and the oil price drops,
you then lose that industry
that you invested so much in.
PROFESSOR: So you might want to
think about risks, in addition
to just what it cost.
Given the history
of the oil price,
given the fact that
1980 is a peak historic,
maybe it's not really
going to continue to rise
as everybody says it is.
Maybe there is just some chance
that the Iranian situation
will settle down and
prices will come back.
So you'd want to
worry about the cost
and you'd want to
worry about the risk.
Anything else you
might want to consider?
Yeah.
STUDENT: You want to worry
about the pollution in terms
of how it relates to oil.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
where I was going.
And this is in 1980.
Climate is not on the table,
but local pollution, all kinds
of other pollution is.
So you might ask the
question, what's this process
look like environmentally?
Then, of course, you would
factor in energy security.
And you reach a decision.
You might also ask, are these
processes really mature?
But in any case, you might
or might not advise--
I would say opinion was
quite mixed on this.
This wasn't going to be
a government industry.
This was going to be a
public-private partnership.
They were going to help
private industry develop, not
build a government industry.
So it wasn't a nutty design.
And it wasn't a nutty
idea, given all the coal.
But a lot of these questions
that you raised, I don't think
were adequately
answered at the time.
So now it's 1986.
Reagan is president.
What happened to oil prices?
I just told you.
They collapsed.
How well has the synthetic
fuels corporation performed?
Well, badly?
Matthew doing the thumbs down.
OK.
Yeah?
STUDENT: About 60%
of the ethanol plants
in the US close by mid-1980s.
So pretty poorly.
PROFESSOR: Well,
this wasn't ethanol.
This was-- well, some
was ethanol, actually.
Yeah.
So should we shut it down?
You should shut it down.
Shut it down.
And the facts-- you'd want
to have the same facts
we had before.
But here's the hypothetical
that I find intriguing.
Suppose oil prices collapse but
the thing that actually worked,
in the sense that the
plants were working,
and it costs twice as
much, but it was domestic.
Would you subsidize it?
Is reduced use of petroleum
based fuels worth it?
STUDENT: I would say
at that point, what
you do is you stick it in your
back pocket as like a safety
card.
And also you've got
to invest in trying
to bring the cost down more
and increase the efficiency, so
in case oil prices jump
again, then you're like,
oh, we had this card
in our back pocket.
PROFESSOR: So you try to
mothball the plants, basically.
Do a little do a little
R&D, mothball the plants.
See if you're going
to upgrade them.
Not bad.
STUDENT: I would say it
depends on the domestic impact.
Because if you're going
with synthetic fuels
and you have like an area
the size of Texas planted
completely with sugar cane--
PROFESSOR: No, these are
coal-based, basically.
So it's strip mining in Wyoming.
You know, nobody lives there.
It's OK you don't want to
look at photos of strip mines.
OK, this would actually be
a more interesting decision.
You'd want to think
about employment,
by the way, if
you're a politician
and you just built this industry
and you said, oh gee, too bad.
Oil prices collapse, you die.
The political pressure to save a
government-sponsored enterprise
would be significant.
And you'd worry about the
environmental impact of running
it and shutting it down.
The cost of subsidizing
down to world prices
would be the equivalent of the
cost of imports, based on this.
That's a lot of money.
You probably wouldn't
want to do that.
It's climate.
What's happened to oil?
It's 2012.
Here we are.
What's happened to
US import dependence?
It's gone up.
What's happened
to CAFE standards?
Not much.
Yes?
The case should have
mentioned, in fact,
it a little bit
overstates the inaction.
So let me correct that.
There was a 2007 law, passed
and signed by President Bush,
that called for increases.
The Bush administration
proposed increases.
The Obama administration
finalized them
for the next several
model years and has
agreement with manufacturers.
So they're moving now.
But from the mid 1980s until
late in the last decade,
nothing happened.
How come?
Rachel?
STUDENT: Well, [INAUDIBLE] for
a while and then the economy
picked up and it
started to go up,
but then the economy
crashed again
And then it became
less of an issue.
PROFESSOR: So energy
really wasn't on the table.
And the auto companies were
being hammered by imports.
And--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Other
things to worry about.
It's always-- and
from the point of view
of the industry, if you
can keep it off the table,
you want it off the table.
People like large, fast cars.
All the R&D went
into performance.
Engines got more efficient.
Lots more efficient.
But they also got bigger.
And cars got bigger.
And we all drove SUVs, and
we're fat and happy, at least,
as I recall.
What's new.
2012, what's the new issue?
Just one word.
One word.
OK, how about a hand?
Logan, what do you think?
STUDENT: Nuclear energy?
PROFESSOR: No, no.
Back in the back?
STUDENT: Climate?
PROFESSOR: Climate.
Hey, there we go.
Climate.
Climate became an agenda item
in Washington in the late 1980s.
In 1992, most of the world
ratified the UN Framework
Convention on Climate Change.
I'm not going to say
something about climate.
We have with us one of
the foremost climate
scientists in the world,
who is going to Kibitz.
And tell me when I say something
wrong, which I probably
will in the next five minutes.
Professor Solomon, a recent
addition to the MIT faculty,
I am flattered that she's here.
And we'll see how this goes.
I'm just going to say a
little bit about climate.
We'll come back to it,
perhaps when she's out of town
and I can get away with more.
I just want to say
a little bit today.
We're going to come back to it.
This is more
political background
and just one conceptual point.
This is the hardest policy
problem I've ever encountered.
And it's hard for a
variety of reasons.
It's hard because
it's a global problem.
It would require
significant actions
by rich and poor countries.
You saw the differences
in energy systems.
All of those different
energy systems
would have to do something
different over the next 20
years and beyond to make a dent.
And inconveniently, we
lack a world government.
So if you think it's hard to
get agreement in Congress,
you can pass a law,
people can be compelled.
Internationally,
you can't do it.
Another issue that makes it
hard is the time scales, right?
Climate is an
intergenerational issue.
CO2, think order of magnets--
it's not a half life,
but in order of magnitude, sort
of a half-life of a century.
There will be a
lot of it around.
Abraham Lincoln's CO2 is
still up there, in quantity.
So we would need
to do things today
to benefit our
great grandchildren.
This is not always an easy sell.
Cost today, benefits
way down the line.
And another thing that's
conceptually hard--
and we're going to play with
this when we do the climate
negotiation exercise--
is it's hard for people to get
their head around the dynamics
involved in CO2.
And we'll do just a 3-minute
exercise to make this point.
So I'm going to ask you
to think through what
a picture would look like.
So here is the
atmospheric concentration
of carbon dioxide.
Just imagine the scenario.
It's risen up to
2000 to 2010-12.
And suppose it gradually
rises and stabilizes.
In fact, this is
pretty aggressive.
It stabilizes at 400
parts per million,
which is quite aggressive.
And here is the
rate at which it's
removed from the atmosphere
by natural processes.
Lets just keep life simple.
Suppose that rate is constant.
Now, think in your
head or draw a picture.
So what I gave you
there was concentration
in the atmosphere.
A scenario-- this is
sort of actual data.
This is suppose.
This is sort of actual
data for emissions.
Suppose that's the rate
at which it's removed
from the atmosphere, right?
So this is gigatons per year.
These are rates.
That was a stock.
These are flows.
What would the
emissions path have
to look like for
this graph to be
consistent with the prior one?
OK, don't answer.
Just form an answer
in your head.
Got it?
Got the picture?
Got the answer?
It has to look like that.
It has to come down to
equal removals at the end,
or it doesn't stabilize.
Right?
Stuff coming out has to
equal stuff coming in.
Water flowing into the
bathtub has to equal water
flowing out of the bathtub.
Now, I assume you all got this
right because you're all smart.
Lots of people don't.
This is a study
published in Science
that used Harvard and
MIT graduate students.
You guys are all smarter
than graduate students.
I understand that.
75% of the sample
didn't get emissions
equal to removals at the end.
They didn't draw a trajectory
that hit at the end.
This is a little tougher,
violating conservation of mass.
That's a little tricky.
But over half asserted,
yeah, you can be stable.
You don't have to
get to the end.
equalize at the end.
Well, these are Harvard
and MIT graduate students.
Lawyers have even more
trouble with this.
Nothing against lawyers.
Some of them once were Harvard
and MIT graduate students.
So this is missed a lot.
And it's a thing that
makes the negotiation
process complicated.
The exercise we're
going to do here
is one that's been run through
with actual negotiators
with the purpose, developed here
by my colleague John Sterman,
of getting them to understand
at an intuitive level
the consequence
of those dynamics.
For this purpose, you think of
the atmosphere as a bathtub.
The height of the water in the
bathtub is the concentration.
Emissions is what
comes out of the faucet
and removals is what
goes down the drain.
If you're worried about
local air pollution that
stays in the
atmosphere for hours,
you just worry about emissions.
You reduce emissions
and you got it.
For this problem,
that doesn't do it.
A sharp cut in emissions is
consistent with the atmosphere
having more and more
greenhouse gases.
That's different.
That complicates the problem.
OK, so I'll just-- a
little more history.
Are there questions about that?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Is the removal
rate proportional
to the concentration of--
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
Is it?
Is the removal rate proportional
to the concentration?
Sort of.
- It can be.
PROFESSOR: It can be.
I just did a constant rate
to make the exercise simpler.
You could imagine it
rising over time slightly.
The same thing would
have to be true.
You'd have to get emissions
down to removals to stabilize.
STUDENT: But [INAUDIBLE]
a little bit more CO2,
the removal rate is rising.
PROFESSOR: You will
stabilize at a higher level.
STUDENT: Yeah, which
is also not good.
PROFESSOR: 400 is
pretty aggressive.
OK, a little bit of history
and then we will chat today.
So again, this is
a set up to what
we'll be doing in two weeks.
Since the '92
convention, there have
been 72 meetings of the
parties to that convention.
The third meeting produced
the Kyoto Protocol,
which obliged rich countries--
those rich countries that
ratified it-- to
reduce emissions.
Many ratified.
We didn't.
And President George W Bush
rejected the protocol in 2001,
and so we are the big
emitter not playing.
There have been
lots more meetings.
The Copenhagen meeting
was widely publicized.
The most recent one
was in South Africa.
17 conferences.
Yeah, most recently in Durban.
You are going to be
conference of the parties,
beginning at the
end of this month,
and you're going to solve this.
OK?
But for now, it's 2012
and we're President Obama.
What do you do about coal?
We have a lot of coal.
It's dirty.
Should we do more of it?
Less of it?
This is not a right
answer question.
This is a what do
you think question.
You surely have opinions.
Yes?
STUDENT: Start with retrofitting
and using point-source capture,
which is getting
reasonably effective.
I mean, even MIT--
you can make these coal
plants better and better.
And that could reduce
your emissions.
PROFESSOR: Well, you can.
We haven't done it
at commercial scale.
You can imagine capturing--
if you're worried
about local pollution,
yeah, you can scrub them
and make them cleaner.
If you're worried
about carbon dioxide,
you can take carbon
dioxide out of flue gas.
It's not cheap.
And then you've got
to put it someplace.
So you can do it, but it
may be quite expensive.
Yeah?
STUDENT: You can retire the
really old, inefficient coal
plants and replace them
with natural gas plants.
PROFESSOR: So you would
say the answer is you
would favor moving off coal.
STUDENT: For the ones
that are inefficient,
that are older than all of them.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Matthew?
STUDENT: Although the CTL
plants weren't successful
when they were
created, it's possible
that we have the technology
now to make them more
successful and less expensive.
PROFESSOR: Which plants?
STUDENT: The coal to--
PROFESSOR: Coal to liquids?
STUDENT: Just because they
tend to pollute less than coal
to electricity does.
PROFESSOR: When burned.
About the same amount
of CO2 lifecycle.
But they burn clean.
STUDENT: So that might be
more efficient or useful.
PROFESSOR: So you might revisit
the coal to liquids question.
Again, we're putting
shale gas off the table
for this discussion.
You might revisit
coal to liquids
to see if we can do it better.
Yeah?
Anybody else, a thought?
Yeah, Scott?
STUDENT: I heard about an
experimental technology that
uses the carbon dioxide
from burning coal
to create cement,
which is also a really
carbon-intensive process.
So looking at processes like
that, or similar to that,
to see if we can develop
on a commercial scale.
PROFESSOR: So you'd
spend some money on R&D
to see if we can find clean ways
to use coal, rather than give
up on it because we've
got so much of it.
And we touched on that one.
Electric vehicles.
Any electric vehicle fans?
Is that a way to use the coal?
Brendan?
STUDENT: Yeah, I
think it makes sense
to move toward electric
vehicles because we can increase
our grid side by adding
additional plants in terms
of looking at natural
gas or nuclear plants
to make up the difference.
PROFESSOR: So you think electric
vehicles are a good thing
to explore, at least.
Cost, an issue?
STUDENT: Well, with projected
rises in oil prices,
not so much.
Not as much as I would
be if they were--
PROFESSOR: I need
to put up a graph
of the forecast of
oil prices in 1980,
which were just
amazing and all wrong.
But, you know, you're right.
If I'm betting money, I'm
betting in the long-run
up, but not down,
particularly with the rise
of with the rise of China.
OK, 30 seconds of
free-for-all before we break.
Any other policies
that we haven't
talked about that we should
have talked about that
will deal with this thing?
Have you a silver bullet?
We've all been looking for one.
STUDENT: I'm extremely
pro-nuclear energy,
but I understand that
it's extremely expensive.
One of the reasons
it's so expensive
is because of all the
regulation and [INAUDIBLE]..
I would like to
reform regulation.
I think that would be-- move
toward a long-term nuclear
solution.
Maybe use natural gas
as an interim solution.
It's easier and cheaper
compared to a natural--
PROFESSOR: Well, there
have been some reforms
to nuclear regulation like
design licensing instead
of plant licensing.
But one issue is Fukushima.
OK--
STUDENT: Fukushima was--
PROFESSOR: I know.
I know.
One last thing I'd
like you to do.
Could you for one
second close your eyes?
Close your eyes.
Because I don't want people
looking at each other.
Those of you who think of
yourselves as libertarians,
small government
Republican-types,
please raise your hands.
Down, please.
Those of you who think of
yourselves as kind of liberal
Democratic,
I-don't-want-the-poor-to-starve,
raise your hands.
OK, you're going to try
to put the Republicans
on one side of this debate and
the Democrats on the other.
We're going to have a bit of a
debate next Tuesday between two
opposing views of the
role of government.
I just wanted to
see how you divide.
There are a lot of agnostics.
Democrats outnumber Republicans.
So think about that as
you read for next week.
Have a good weekend.